look at the butt on that for you look at
that crack bro hello recognize me now
Matt but you will see blue in your
nightmare
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you always get me with that what's
up everybody
comedian hates news travel we're back in
another episode of that goes contou
today we're gonna talk about burritos
and look there's a rivalry people say
San Francisco got the best burritos some
people say San Diego got the best
burritos la they're like now you guys
are not a contender in this kind of a
burrito playing field I beg to differ
because today I'm gonna do you one
better I'm gonna put you up on game
hello how you doing all right
still got it still got it baby he she
undressed me with them eyes cougar I'm
gonna downtown LA we're about to start
this journey of finding the best burrito
out here we're waiting for Blake to get
here from workaholics actually he's
right over here
Blake for workaholics let's go meet him
[Music]
what's up bro thanks for being here
what's up I'm excited to be here I often
call burritos like human batteries
because I just put in the whole recharge
it's a full repo
yeah there's no way to get me to my peak
level that's like burritos will get me
there yeah I love burritos I feel like a
burrito is like a duffel bag of topics
that's what's up
a little sleeping bag you can just cozy
in you're right yeah it's like top three
things I want to eat in my life are you
a kind of guy that eats half a burrito
and says hey can I get a box to go cover
absolutely not no I was going down right
there clean plate Club like yeah no
survivors all right man
you ready for this thing we're here at
Sonora town we're gonna hit this spot
and then we're gonna go down the bull
heights a hit there this flap that's it
just to I have the room they're little
Sonoran burritos and they're filled with
asados have either shredded chicken or
shredded beef so what does should be me
chimichanga
is just a burrito that you follow it's
just how you would say it in Mexico
versus chimichangas here which are like
deep-fried cities covered in sour cream
and everything that is a very old
cookbook from TOS grandmother that
references the chippy the grill marks
potentional yeah it's like a panini bro
okay yeah I'm trying appeal to my homey
right yeah yes to speak in weird white
man turn Dini marks on it this is off a
mesquite grill
Sonora is known for having like a ranch
staff culture so anytime you get
together with your friends and family
it's gonna be a round of grill and
you're gonna be having a carne asada I
heard that the flour you bring from Max
bring it over the border myself the
wheat in sonoda is softer than the wheat
here and so it results in a more pliable
Tex really delicious tortilla you're
bringing flour over the border you ever
get jammed up of LaHaye is this really
flour definitely yeah they want to taste
it gonna taste yeah bring it over in
like ceramic dogs
no need I can't wait for you to sink
your teeth into these beauties I take
out my watermelon gum yeah yeah you kind
of want to clean the palate okay so what
do we do with this off oh boy yeah so
will you doc so we'll use like the big
onion this is some what you thought okay
this is con just like the tassel like
you graduate into real Mexican food flip
it over like yeah are you graduated you
know this is perfect yeah sorry bro they
took a bite but see what's up wait I got
to put on my shades to wash them oh all
right good innit row Wow oh okay so this
is like a pool chicken it just slaps
right it's nice and tender they're
really juicy I'm gonna try this bean and
cheese one this is like when you're you
know broke student you go the bean
cheese VRC I'm gonna hold off on the on
the big one
why would you do that I'm allergic for
one beans I have to go
all right that's it I'm s I'm just
kidding I'm not gonna leave these
burritos I'll take yours yes yeah you
can have mine done see the more the
merrier I gotta hang out with you more
dude dude I got bottomless burritos this
I'll find out I'm allergic to beans so
when I was little
uh-huh my mom gave me beans and I got
really sick and the doctor literally
tells my mom is like please do not give
your son beans my mom goes you're full
of [ __ ] like we don't know like yeah mom
he's only a doctor what does he know so
I remember my mom sneaking in like beans
and like burritos just a little bit now
would get like an itchy I'm like what's
that beans like mom are you trying to
kill me no you know what she was doing
well know how like they'll be hollering
yeah if you give little drops of like
snake venom you
like one with the snake I've never heard
that yeah yeah I think I think you dude
really smart
oh there's them yeah like kids try at
home I I think your mom had a plan to
get you a burrito ready I'm gonna talk
to you about workaholics I'm a big fan
of the show and one of the motifs in the
show is this burrito burritos did pop up
quite a bit in episodes ooh but it makes
sense because life is kind of just a
sequence of burritos yeah you and the
show's Eiger like I said she's a
quintessential slacker and if you were
action figure came in a box like with
the you know toy bong and buried bong
and burrito right and the glasses now I
well yeah yeah well hopefully if Oakley
will give me the plug Oakley come on
y'all smoke Lee we came up with that
collab smoke please hit me up smoke
watcher hey sonic Jace all right we did
some good work here you want to roll out
to the next back I would love to I'm
still starving
you're still starving oh yeah yeah after
that I'm a bottomless pit I'm gonna put
you on game of this next ride oh I can't
forget these
[Music]
have fun
this place is cute as hell yeah huh yeah
this is like a nice lunch it's cozy
you know it's like get the bells over
nice cute little Church escalation on
27s out front the church right yeah I
think that might be Birdman remember you
know it's good tacos and Birdman's here
last TECA that's it voted the best
burrito in LA and says yeah real if
you're like a real burrito enthusiast if
you're like wow they did it in oh six
sounds like a big year for burrito Oh
like if you have the oh six chip right
[Music]
Oh shells into the devil day is one with
no beef with everything thank you gonna
have to say that loud yeah I mean people
don't know that I'm allergic to beans
well oh is that crazy for a Mexicans
will know I'm actually allergic myself
my family gets to see this too man they
used to just light me up
thank you man we're excited to be here
stick how long have you guys been open
so place has been open since the 1960s
originally what they did was just simply
a tortilla it's a mono and they're not
that means at me yes your money and then
I later broke
and then about like a decade ago we
started to introduce food as ten years
were like well we introduced our with
the Chilean
that's a chilly stuff with cheese you
told me early oh okay
I retain information okay I'm gonna make
this bun recognize she liver you know
recognize just recognize yeah yeah I can
see you like wait I know that did you
know Wilson High School
Oh for so I don't feel you guys make a
day close to five hundred five now and
that's just a breed or that's um carpal
tunnel waiting to happen
doing this over and over again hey I'm
excited to try this man thank you so
much for having us you're welcome
let's dig it once again look at the butt
on that breathe look at that crack hello
recognize me now Matt but you will see
blue your nightmares
look hey all right okay let's go see
liver yeah no first bite oh sure yeah
this is feeling like a real la burrito
to me for sure that's a slippery pepper
so that's the money shot put that in
slow-mo resistance-band
but you get bigger - Inez that's the
best workout I've ever seen my life
[Music]
you consider yourself an improviser a
sketch what will you feel most
comfortable being identified in I mean I
think I've kind of found my love for
like comedy and acting through like
improv for sure I'm just a huge fan of
like collaborative efforts I think like
comedy or any kind of product or are
like only gets better when there's more
opinions as long as they're the opinions
of people you respect and all that so if
you've got a good scene room you're
gonna get a good product out of it like
the wu-tang clan like the wu-tang clan
yeah every everyone plays a positional
interview yeah they form Voltron
Voltron cancer planet there you go yeah
I mean Power Rangers Power Rangers kind
of a Voltron ripoff
yeah I see that actually where do you
draw your inspiration from is it like
other improvisers like oh jeez or is it
like music or do you kind of get that
inspiration for your company I mean
there's definitely likes correlation
with like freestyle rappers and all that
like freestyle rapping is a form of in
improvisation you know what I mean yeah
what rapper do you see yourself most
like waka flocka flame waka flocka flash
I'm pretty much a mirror image of waka
okay yeah I just I get in the club I
throw bows I make it clap and then I'm
out I feel that's my improv style I
respect it a whole lot yeah I yes and
but with my elbows yes and what
[ __ ] do you ever see yourself
trying stand-up or is that something
you've done before in the past I've
never done stand-up I mean I definitely
like having a huge respect for stand-up
comedy I think it's like a super high
art form when it's like done correctly
because you can really come with a
perspective runner you can see a
stand-up that really makes you truly
like
like that's real spit I feel like
stannum comments are really like the
modern-day philosophers cuz what
happened back then you had Socrates or
Plato they would go to the plaza and
kind of talk about their point of view
they're taking live questions that they
hadn't if you look at it stand-up
comedy's very much sad the plaza is not
the comedy club the comment goes up
there and he's like hey you know if you
have people laughing you've got them
you've got them listening and you know
what I mean right
the performer needs your undivided
attention I need to be paying attention
to get that response I'm sure you've
done those shows at bars where they do
not want comedy like going on at all
they're not paying attention it is so
hard and then they turn off the TVs and
other piss because they gotta listen to
you [ __ ] where's the Rams game yeah bear
with me here yeah can I get a
relationship so you guys are dating okay
okay [ __ ] you yeah okay
I heard [ __ ] you [ __ ] you this is gonna
be a dirty saying where are we
your mothers are all right thank you
that's why so we had two burritos today
we had two spots which one are you
feeling the most I'm pumped I could say
I recognized the Brio and I've had it so
I have some street cred right but you're
probably gonna find me at the hipster
joint because they're smuggling the
flower oh yeah fred's oh that's bills
they're putting in the legwork
yeah well best of luck to you man thanks
again and hopefully we get to grab a
burrito soon I would love that in your
neck of the woods okay he's not being
sarcastic either it's just a yes and
like I would love that yeah I'm seeing
I'm serious oh really okay yeah we're
not improv right now I would say no oh
okay my man yeah I respect let's thank
you man [ __ ] get some burritos I'm
down bro yes don't I made a friend I
need to use the bathroom now this
burrito really got to me okay
I felt like this was going pretty edge
roses credits that's end of the episode
or gangster we're not in a biker gang no
no we're not I look like a rejected
biker he's trying if you're a biker gang
and you're watching
Hazen's in
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter tacos tacos
bro hey Suz Trejo is in the building
tacos con todo a new show on first we
feast Tuesdays at 11 a.m. this is the
initiation a last dab taco oh yeah hey
Suz Trejo
welcome to the family mom thanks ma'am
this is gonna hurt tomorrow